so you may remember back when Barack
Obama was president that there were
these conspiracy theories that were
cited with no evidence that maybe
President Obama wouldn't relinquish
control of the White House he wouldn't
leave the presidency he might try to
change the law to allow presidents to
continue to run indefinitely or he might
do something to the Constitution of
course not understanding what that would
entail
maybe President Obama would declare
martial law and suspend the 2016
election and of course there was no
reason to think that would happen
because President Obama never mentioned
anything about it there was no actual
evidence that it was something he would
do and it was very clear that there was
a full election taking place and that
Barack Obama was not going to seize
indefinite control of the Oval Office
still insanely unlikely that Donald
Trump would do something like it but in
contrast to under Barack Obama Donald
Trump has actually said after China
changed the law to allow the president
to continue running Trump said
president-for-life sounds pretty
interesting maybe it's something that we
would do here in the United States in
the future
Donald Trump has implied before that if
he were to lose a presidential election
it could only be by fraud you might
remember that during the 2016 election
he was actually asked if you lose will
you accept the result and he said well
we'll see not even willing to say yeah
if I lose I lost and then to add to all
of this Donald Trump's own former
personal lawyer Michael Cohen said
during his testimony last week that he
fears Donald Trump will not peaceably
transfer power if he loses the 20/20
election let's take a listen to that
clip and I will not sit back say nothing
and allow him to do the same to the
country indeed given my experience
working for mr. Trump I fear that if he
loses the election in 2020 that there
will never be a peaceful transition of
power and this is why I agreed to appear
before you today so tons of people
emailing me saying how could a president
even try to stay in power like how could
he try not to leave who would act
remove him so let's actually play it out
there's a few primary scenarios here so
let's take it seriously let's deal with
it once and then we can sort of move on
the first example is like the simplest
one imagine that there's some kind of
psychotic episode a mental health thing
where Trump is refusing to leave but is
not coherently contesting the results of
the election and his administration's
not contesting it that's the simplest
situation I think Secret Service just
removes Trump maybe with with mental
health professionals like I don't think
that that's really the most complicated
scenario I also don't think it's the
most likely scenario what we're really
talking about here is that the election
is closed maybe it's contested and
ultimately Donald Trump as well as his
administration and staff decide they
don't believe Trump actually lost you'd
have a president elect you'd have that
president elect in touch with the FBI
and the Secret Service and the Justice
Department and the Joint Chiefs of Staff
of the military and there would be a
physical removal of the president period
it's insane it's crazy but in a
situation like that that's how it would
go down but that gets us to the
importance of the military and again I'm
doing this because people are emailing
about it I'm doing it because Michael
Cohen suggested that it would happen
last week not because I think this is a
likely scenario authoritarians being
able to stay in power often comes down
to support by the military if we talk
about Venezuela for example ultimately
whether Nicolas Maduro stays or goes
could come down to whether the military
backs Nicolas Maduro if indeed the
military backed Trump not leaving power
then you are all of a sudden talking
about a coup d'etat right a coup by the
state is that likely I don't think so
this is something that is often said
about other presidents they're never
going to leave the White House they're
going to refuse to relinquish control
and it's bogus
and here it's also probably bogus the
differences we have Trump statement
about
maybe accepting election results we have
Trump's statement about it sounds pretty
good president for life and we have
Michael Cohen's statement here so Pat
for the good of the country I hope that
it never actually comes to this but I
think that those are the ways that it
would play out if it did come to that
point in time I can't imagine that if
there is a decree from a Supreme Court
or from a Federal Elections Commission
or whatever that Donald Trump has lost I
don't know how the military supports
Trump just staying in power I think that
our system of checks and balances here
in the u.s. is strong enough so that
even if Trump decides that he's not
going to concede it won't matter at the
end of the day because he'll be taking
out one way or another but I don't think
it'll come to that because Trump has
shown signs that he's willing to cave
when he knows that he's lost like on
family separations and the government
shutdown recently so I don't think it'll
come to that he may refuse to attend the
inaugural of whoever defeats him but I
think that's about it yeah I think the
most likely scenario is that this is not
a thing but since Michael Cohen
mentioned it and there's actually more
to make us think about it than with any
recent president I can think of we've
talked about it that's how it would work
and now we can move on to bigger and
better things one of today's sponsors is
privacy dot-com / Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from
company's being hacked which we've been
talking about for a while on the program
and it's perfect for signing up for free
trial somewhere if you don't want your
real credit card number to be exposed
and on file and their app and browser
extension let you autofill the virtual
credit card number into the credit card
field when you're buying things online
there are a ton of different advantages
to shopping and paying bills with a
system like this everything is totally
secure and encrypted and in some
situations you can earn 5% cash back on
your purchases it's all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time everybody in our audience
who signs up gets $5.00 towards your
first purchase when you sign up using
that link below